selamat datang kembali di Quantum Computing in Practice, aku host kamu Olivia Lanes, terakhir kali kita bahas contoh pendekatan
Quantum Computing untuk masalah optimasi yang dikenal sebagai Max cut menggunakan formulasi QUBO, kita
masuk cukup dalam tapi itu hanya satu contoh dari satu pendekatan, hari ini kita akan membahas aplikasi near-term
secara lebih luas dan mengembangkan intuisi kita untuk berbagai jenis masalah yang kita harapkan akan menemukan solusi Quantum yang berguna
dan melihat beberapa contoh terbaru dari pekerjaan penting yang dilakukan di komunitas kita pada skala
utilitas, sebelumnya kita sempat membahas bahwa tidak semua masalah butuh tambahan kekuatan komputasi
khususnya Quantum Computing untuk diselesaikan secara efisien, ini adalah masalah yang paling kamu kenal
seperti aritmatika, scroll media sosial, mungkin main Tetris, Doom atau video game lainnya, kita secara umum menganggap
ini sebagai masalah mudah, di sisi lain ada masalah yang sangat sulit seperti menemukan faktor prima dari bilangan
bulat yang sangat besar dan ini adalah dasar dari enkripsi RSA dan apa yang sebenarnya dirancang untuk diselesaikan oleh algoritma Shor, contoh lain
adalah menemukan solusi dalam dataset yang tidak terurut, ini secara teoritis bisa diselesaikan oleh algoritma kuantum yang dikenal
sebagai algoritma Grover, namun sebagian besar ahli setuju bahwa jenis algoritma ini akan memerlukan
implementasi error correction dan kita secara teknologi belum sampai sana, jadi saat kita melanjutkan dalam
pelajaran ini dan dalam perjalanan pendidikan Quantum kamu, ingat kita sedang mencari sweet spot di suatu tempat di sini di tengah
ini adalah masalah yang sulit dipecahkan tapi itulah yang membuatnya sangat menyenangkan, satu hal yang belum banyak kita bahas
adalah teori kompleksitas komputasional, salah satu alasannya adalah bisa agak menakutkan dan ya
memang kompleks, teori kompleksitas komputasional adalah bidang ilmu komputer yang bertujuan mengklasifikasikan masalah komputasi
berdasarkan seberapa sulitnya, ada banyak sekali kelas kompleksitas berbeda dalam komputasi klasik tapi yang paling
fundamental adalah masalah P, ini adalah masalah yang bisa diselesaikan dalam waktu polinomial seiring bertambahnya skala
masalah, artinya mudah untuk diselesaikan, tipe masalah yang lebih sulit berikutnya adalah masalah NP yang
merupakan singkatan dari non-deterministic polynomial, ini adalah masalah yang jawabannya bisa diverifikasi dalam waktu polinomial tapi tidak
harus diselesaikan, berikutnya adalah NP complete dan sekarang kita masuk ke masalah yang benar-benar menantang tanpa
solusi polinomial yang diketahui, di sinilah masalah terkenal seperti traveling salesman problem dan bahkan permainan
Sudoku berada, sekarang ketika Quantum Computing muncul setidaknya secara teori, orang menghabiskan upaya yang cukup besar untuk mencoba
mencari tahu kelas masalah apa yang bisa diselesaikan oleh jenis komputer baru ini secara efisien, sebuah kelas baru
masalah ditemukan yang disebut bounded error quantum polynomial problems atau BQP untuk singkatnya, definisi ketatnya
agak panjang tapi ini adalah kelas masalah keputusan yang bisa diselesaikan oleh komputer kuantum dalam waktu polinomial dengan
peluang error yang kecil, ada peluang error karena pengukuran kuantum memang inherently acak tapi
probabilitas error bisa dibuat sekecil mungkin, sekarang semua kelas ini berada dalam kelas yang lebih besar yang kita sebut PSPACE dan di sinilah
kita berpikir BQP berada relatif terhadap semua jenis masalah lainnya tapi sangat sulit untuk membuktikan ini secara definitif
secara matematis, kamu akan melihat bahwa masalah BQP Quantum tidak harus tumpang tindih dengan masalah NP complete
namun kamu mungkin masih pernah melihat beberapa pendekatan Quantum Computing yang bertujuan menyelesaikan masalah NP complete, kenapa
begitu? satu kesalahpahaman umum adalah bahwa tidak ada gunanya mengeksplorasi solusi
untuk masalah seperti traveling salesman dan masalah NP complete lainnya untuk komputer kuantum, atau masalah apa pun di mana
bukti matematika untuk percepatan Quantum belum ditemukan, namun ini tidak harus demikian adanya
menemukan bukti matematis bahwa algoritma Quantum lebih cepat dari padanannya yang klasik itu langka, Shor dan
Grover adalah dua dari hanya segelintir contoh di mana ini telah dilakukan sejauh ini tapi itu nggak masalah, bahkan
ilmuwan komputer belum bisa membuktikan bahwa kelas P dan NP itu berbeda meskipun semua intuisi
memberi tahu kita bahwa memang begitu, juga membandingkan dua algoritma dan cara skalanya sering melihat skenario kasus terburuk
untuk masing-masing, sangat mungkin bahwa dalam praktiknya skenario kasus terburuk bukan yang kita temukan di kehidupan nyata, jadi
jangan berkecil hati, kita perkenalkan sebagai gantinya ide solusi heuristik, kalau kamu seorang
eksperimentalis kamu sudah tahu dan menyukai jenis solusi ini, heuristik adalah pendekatan apa pun untuk menyelesaikan
masalah yang pragmatis tapi tidak harus optimal dan itu bagus karena solusi tidak harus
optimal untuk sangat berguna, misalnya bayangkan aplikasi keuangan, kita belum menemukan percepatan
eksponensial untuk sebagian besar algoritma keuangan yang bisa digunakan Quantum tapi itu tidak harus jadi masalah, kita tidak butuh solusi optimal
dalam keuangan setidaknya karena solusi yang bahkan hanya 1% lebih efisien bisa setara dengan miliaran dolar
keuntungan, jadi bagaimana kita tahu kasus penggunaan dan masalah apa yang bisa cocok untuk Quantum Computing saat ini dan yang aku maksud adalah
ada alasan kuat untuk meyakini Quantum utility atau bahkan Advantage bisa ditemukan baik sekarang atau
dalam waktu dekat, mungkin lebih mudah untuk pertama-tama menyebutkan hal-hal yang pasti tidak boleh dimiliki masalah tersebut,
tidak bisa memerlukan jumlah qubit yang sangat banyak, kita belum memiliki prosesor yang memiliki ribuan hingga jutaan qubit tersedia, itulah salah satu alasan utama
algoritma Shor dan sejenisnya masih sangat jauh, circuit juga tidak bisa sangat dalam, sangat sulit bagi aku
untuk memberi tahu kamu persis kedalaman circuit mana yang tidak akan berhasil karena tergantung pada begitu banyak faktor tapi secara umum kalau
eksperimen kamu memerlukan kedalaman yang belum pernah kamu lihat dicapai dalam literatur, kamu mungkin akan kesulitan dan
terakhir, jenis algoritma apa pun yang kita tahu akan memerlukan error correction belum bisa dilakukan, apa yang harus kita cari adalah eksperimen yang memanfaatkan
sebagian besar qubit yang tersedia di QPU mana pun, kita juga telah menekankan
pentingnya error mitigation dan suppression dan terakhir harus ada perluasan yang jelas ke aplikasi masa depan
yang akan penting bagi masyarakat dan yang bisa kita lihat akhirnya mengarah pada Quantum
Advantage, sekarang mari kita bahas beberapa contoh kasus penggunaan yang masuk dalam tiga kategori utama yang telah
kita identifikasi sebagai yang paling mungkin menghasilkan hasil yang menguntungkan dalam jangka pendek hingga menengah
area pertama adalah simulasi alam, kita sudah membahas ini sebelumnya, ada
begitu banyak peluang bagi komputer kuantum untuk meningkatkan penelitian yang dilakukan di tingkat molekuler dan atom
WEBVTT
dan alasannya adalah karena metode klasik saat ini dibatasi oleh deskripsi matematis yang pada dasarnya tidak efisien
dari struktur atom, menyimpan dan memanipulasi Quantum State memerlukan jumlah sumber daya yang eksponensial
pada komputer klasik tapi bisa dilakukan secara efisien pada komputer kuantum dan itulah yang membuat simulasi material
dan pemodelan kimia menjadi beberapa area aplikasi yang paling menjanjikan, lebih khususnya ini bisa mengarah pada
perkembangan dalam penyerapan karbon dioksida, baterai alternatif atau penemuan obat-obatan baru, beberapa
algoritma yang sangat relevan di area ini adalah variational quantum eigensolver VQE yang digunakan untuk
memperkirakan sifat-sifat tertentu dari suatu material seperti keseimbangan atau state energi minimum, contoh lain adalah
time dynamic simulation TDS, algoritma itu digunakan untuk memperkirakan fungsi respons atau sifat spektral dari
material dan aku juga mau menyebutkan pendatang baru yaitu sample based quantum diagonalization yang menurut kita akan
banyak kita dengar di masa depan dekat, area aplikasi berikutnya adalah optimasi, sekarang optimasi cukup
umum dalam komputasi seperti yang bisa kamu bayangkan, jadi kasus penggunaannya cukup banyak dan beragam
namun beberapa contoh yang sering kita dengar adalah optimasi portofolio dalam keuangan, desain industri dan juga
distribusi dan supply chain, algoritma paling umum yang mungkin akan kamu dengar terkait dengan optimasi adalah yang
sudah kita bahas dengan cukup mendalam yaitu quantum approximate optimization algorithm atau
qaoa, terakhir satu area yang banyak mendapat antusias dalam beberapa tahun terakhir adalah quantum machine learning, sekarang
aku rasa adil untuk mengatakan bahwa sepertinya QML tidak akan terjadi secepat simulasi dalam segala kemungkinan tapi meski begitu ada
beberapa algoritma yang mengesankan yang sedang dikerjakan orang secara konsisten yang sesuai dengan beberapa kasus penggunaan
yang sangat penting, beberapa kemungkinan kasus penggunaan ini adalah pemrosesan bahasa alami, analisis lalu lintas jaringan dan bahkan deteksi
penipuan dalam transaksi keuangan, algoritma yang relevan di area ini adalah quantum support vector
machine, quantum neural networks dan quantum generative adversarial networks, sekarang untuk mengklarifikasi tiga
kelompok yang baru saja kita gambarkan adalah area aplikasi yang luas, juga perlu dicatat bahwa di komunitas ada
manfaat juga bagi kelompok-kelompok yang bekerja sama yang fokus pada topik tertentu, IBM memimpin sebuah inisiatif tidak lama
yang lalu yang disebut Working groups untuk mencoba membantu para kolaborator bertemu dan menciptakan Synergy yang produktif di empat area spesifik
yaitu healthcare dan ilmu kehidupan, material dan HPC, fisika energi tinggi dan
optimasi, berikut adalah kelompok-kelompok kita saat ini dan entitas yang terlibat dalam upaya tersebut, kalau kamu mau mendengar lebih banyak tentang
apa yang dilakukan working groups kita telah melampirkan empat white paper mereka di deskripsi di bawah, seperti yang tadi aku katakan
aku pikir hal terbaik yang bisa dilakukan di tahap kursus ini adalah meluangkan waktu mengeksplorasi jenis masalah apa yang sedang dikerjakan orang di garis terdepan
teknologi ini dan mengembangkan intuisi kita untuk mengetahui jenis algoritma apa yang akan berhasil dan bagaimana
menerapkannya, dan sebelum kita mulai aku hanya ingin memperjelas bahwa tujuan utama di sini bukan untuk memahami setiap
detail dari eksperimen, jenis analisis ini bisa sangat menakutkan bahkan bagi para ahli jika papernya sedikit
di luar bidang keahlian kamu, tujuannya hanyalah untuk membantu mengembangkan intuisi untuk jenis masalah yang
cocok untuk komputer kuantum dan cara menanganinya, dan kalau kamu tertarik dengan detailnya dan ini telah memicu beberapa
ide kamu sendiri aku sangat mendorong kamu untuk pergi dan membaca paper lengkapnya sendiri, kasus penggunaan spesifik dan
paper yang akan kita lihat secara mendalam adalah ini, pertama kita akan mengeksplorasi paper yang membahas
simulasi dinamika hadron, ini masuk dalam kategori fisika energi tinggi, berikutnya kita akan melihat
masalah optimasi khususnya biased field counter adiabatic quantum optimization dan terakhir kita akan melihat masalah
simulasi lain tapi kali ini berfokus pada mRNA, molekul krusial untuk
pengembangan obat dan terapeutik, kalau kamu familiar atau tidak dengan paper-paper ini tidak masalah, kita akan menelusuri
semuanya, ketiganya adalah paper penting yang menangani masalah berukuran besar dan menunjukkan bagaimana komputer kuantum
mulai digunakan sebagai metode penyelidikan ilmiah lainnya, yang pertama adalah mensimulasikan dinamika
hadron dan kita akan mendalami sebuah paper oleh kelompok Martin Savage di University of Washington yang berjudul Quantum
simulations of hadron dynamics in the Schwinger model using 112
qubits, kalau kamu bukan fisikawan energi tinggi kamu mungkin masih familiar dengan istilah hadron seperti dalam
Large Hadron Collider atau LHC yang merupakan akselerator partikel raksasa berkeliling 27 kilometer yang memungkinkan
untuk akhirnya mengamati Higgs Boson, hadron adalah partikel komposit subatom yang terdiri dari partikel
kecil lainnya yang disebut quark, beberapa contohnya adalah neutron dan proton, untuk sedikit konteks LHC dibangun
untuk memungkinkan studi fisika fundamental dan apa yang terjadi pada partikel ketika mereka bertabrakan pada energi super tinggi
dalam tabung melingkar ini, dengan melakukan ini para ilmuwan berharap belajar lebih banyak tentang bagaimana alam semesta awal terbentuk
dan seperti yang aku katakan sebelumnya juga digunakan untuk menemukan Boson yang merupakan partikel sulit dipahami yang bertanggung jawab atas massa dari
partikel fundamental, sekarang pada prinsipnya interaksi partikel-partikel ini bisa
disimulasikan dari awal hingga akhir dengan komputer kuantum yang cukup kuat, kita belum sampai di sana tapi kemajuan
sedang dibuat, sekarang model Schwinger adalah model sederhana yang digunakan untuk mensimulasikan beberapa dinamika ini dan telah muncul sebagai salah satu
model pilihan yang paling populer, detail model ini tidak super penting untuk saat ini tapi bagi yang
penasaran itu adalah model yang mendeskripsikan perilaku elektron dan positron yang berinteraksi melalui foton dalam 1 + 1 D
dimensi artinya ada satu dimensi spasial dan waktu, model ini memiliki banyak kesamaan dengan Quantum
chromodynamics yang mendeskripsikan bagaimana quark dan hadron berinteraksi, sekarang itu sangat sulit untuk disimulasikan jadi
model Schwinger sering digunakan sebagai toy model untuk menyelidiki beberapa fenomena yang sebenarnya umum untuk
keduanya, sekarang cara kita akan melanjutkan dengan contoh ini dan sisa contoh yang aku pilih di sini adalah
dengan mengajukan serangkaian pertanyaan kepada diri kita sendiri, yang pertama adalah mengapa kita punya alasan untuk percaya bahwa mensimulasikan ini
di komputer kuantum akan berhasil sama sekali, dalam kasus ini elektron dan positron dalam model Schwinger memiliki efek penyaringan
yang menyebabkan korelasi antara fermion yang jauh meluruh secara eksponensial dengan pemisahan dan ini berarti bahwa
WEBVTT
tidak banyak interaksi jarak jauh dari qubit di satu sisi chip ke sisi lainnya di chip
yang kita tahu sangat rentan error, jadi ini benar-benar bagus untuk hardware yang kita miliki saat ini, berikutnya adalah
apakah topik ini bahkan menarik? well aku harap aku sudah cukup meyakinkan kamu bahwa ya fisika energi tinggi sangat
menarik, orang-orang bersedia menghabiskan miliaran dolar untuk membangun LHC dan ribuan ilmuwan dan
teknisi di seluruh dunia telah mendedikasikan hidup mereka untuk bidang ini, itulah betapa pentingnya itu tapi
model Schwinger itu sederhana dan tidak dirancang untuk mencakup tiga dimensi spasial, meski begitu ini adalah
model yang penting karena masih menyediakan irisan yang saat ini dapat diuji dan penyederhanaan berguna dari teori
penuh, terakhir bagaimana pekerjaan ini dilakukan atau pendekatan apa yang akan mereka gunakan kalau mereka ingin melanjutkan pekerjaan dalam
eksperimen tipe simulasi? VQE adalah salah satu pendekatan yang paling umum dan langkah pertama hampir selalu sama
yaitu menyiapkan ground state, dalam kasus ini adalah vacuum state dan dalam eksperimen ini mereka menggunakan versi baru VQE yang disebut SC
adapt VQE untuk menyiapkan baik ground state maupun hadron wave packet di atas vacuum tersebut, langkah berikutnya adalah
membiarkan hadron berevolusi atau merambat dalam waktu, terakhir kita perlu mengidentifikasi
observable yang ingin kita deteksi, sekarang kalau langkah-langkah itu terdengar agak familiar bagimu minus bagian hadron wave
packet itu karena langkah-langkah ini sangat mirip dengan apa yang kita bahas dalam contoh qaoa di episode sebelumnya
mudah-mudahan kamu mulai melihat beberapa pola yang muncul di sini, komponen yang diperlukan untuk VQE sangat mirip dengan qaoa
kita mulai dalam state yang familiar, di sini vacuum state dan kemudian kita biarkan berevolusi dalam waktu dengan serangkaian hamiltonians yang
dieksponensiasi dibagi menjadi potongan-potongan yang bisa dikelola di mana n adalah jumlah pembagian, satu-satunya perbedaan besar di sini
adalah kita membuat wave packet hadron yang berpusat dalam circuit kita sebelum kita mulai membiarkannya berevolusi, jadi bagaimana ini
dilakukan? well vacuum state adalah ground state dan kita sudah cukup membahas cara memetakan ini, sekarang menyiapkan hadron
wave packet agak berbeda, pada vacuum ini sebuah hadron bisa dieksitasi dengan membuat pasangan fermion anti-fermion pada
site yang berdekatan, dengan menyiapkan superposisi dari hadron-hadron seperti itu di lokasi yang berbeda, sebuah wave packet
arbitrer bisa disiapkan, para penulis memusatkan wave packet mereka di tengah circuit untuk mengamati evolusi
tanpa melampaui batas tapi ingat nama permainannya ketika bekerja dengan QPU yang noisy adalah menjaga
kedalaman circuit tetap terkendali, untuk melakukan ini protokol SC adapt VQE menggunakan simetri dan
hierarki dalam skala panjang untuk menentukan Quantum circuit berkedalaman rendah untuk persiapan state, idenya adalah bahwa ini
akan membuat ansatz dengan jumlah parameter yang lebih kecil yang setara dengan kedalaman yang lebih dangkal, detail lebih lanjut tentu
bisa ditemukan di paper daripada yang ada waktu kita bahas di sini jadi pastikan untuk memeriksanya, sekarang mari kita lihat hasilnya, eksperimen ini dijalankan pada
perangkat IBM Quantum Heron dan mengimplementasikan beberapa jenis air mitigation dan suppression
termasuk teknik yang lebih baru yang disebut operator decoherence renormalization serta dynamical decoupling, zero noise
extrapolation dan Pauli twirling, sekarang mari kita coba menginterpretasikan data, observable yang sebenarnya akan
kita ukur untuk mengamati bagaimana wave packet merambat adalah sesuatu yang disebut chiral condensate yang agak
abstrak tapi pada dasarnya adalah fase superfluida dari hadron, sekarang kita bisa melihat wave packet yang berpusat di sini pada
site yang telah ditentukan untuk menjalankan eksperimen ini di mana warna sesuai dengan chiral condensate,
sisi kiri menunjukkan hasil bebas error dari simulator sementara sisi kanan menunjukkan hasil dari komputer kuantum
IBM Torino, idealnya ini akan menjadi cerminan satu sama lain karena simetri jadi kamu bisa melihat bahwa ada
beberapa ketidaksempurnaan, sekarang sumbu y vertikal ini sesuai dengan potongan waktu yang
aku ukur sebelumnya jadi mengapa kita tidak mengambil beberapa potongan horizontal melalui langkah waktu pertama dan terakhir dari data untuk melihat
apa yang terjadi pada wave packet, pada waktu tau sama dengan 1 di sini dalam warna oranye yang sesuai dengan
potongan ini kamu bisa melihat bahwa chiral condensate sempit dan terlokalisasi, ini juga sesuai dengan sangat baik dengan
simulasi yang dilakukan untuk perbandingan, pada tau 14 meski begitu jauh lebih menyebar dan kurang
terlokalisasi, mungkin perbandingan dengan simulator tidak begitu sempurna sekarang tapi kamu masih jelas bisa melihat kesepakatan yang sangat baik antara teori dan data
yang menggembirakan, sebagai kesimpulan ini adalah contoh yang sangat keren dari jenis pekerjaan simulasi yang mungkin tidak awalnya kamu pikirkan untuk
diterapkan pada komputer kuantum tapi sebenarnya kamu bisa dan berhasil, memang tidak sempurna tapi kamu tidak harus jadi
ahli fisika partikel untuk melihat bahwa komputer kuantum secara akurat memprediksi propagasi keluar dari wave packet
yang persis seperti yang kita harapkan untuk ditemukan, semoga pekerjaan masa depan di area ini akan terus berlanjut dan para fisikawan energi tinggi
akan terus menemukan cara untuk memasukkan Quantum Computing ke dalam alur kerja mereka, tujuannya adalah untuk menyelesaikan masalah teoritis dengan lebih presisi dan
masalah yang tidak bisa dilakukan secara klasik dan menggunakan eksperimen untuk menerima atau menolak teori dengan harapan menemukan
fisika baru, membangun detektor yang lebih baik dan mengarah pada pemahaman yang lebih baik tentang alam pada tingkat paling fundamental
nya, contoh berikutnya berfokus pada optimasi dan akan menjadi penyelaman mendalam ke dalam paper yang disebut biased field
digitized counter adiabatic quantum optimization yang dilakukan oleh anggota tim kipu quantum di
University of the Basque Country di Spanyol, kita akan mulai seperti yang kita lakukan sebelumnya
dengan serangkaian definisi, yang pertama adalah counter adiabatic yang merupakan jenis evolusi yang menekan efek non-adiabatik
yang dialami oleh sistem terlepas dari seberapa cepat proses-proses tersebut terjadi, ingat teori adiabatik dari
episode terakhir, kamu biasanya perlu membiarkan sistem berevolusi sangat lambat jika kamu ingin ia tetap berada di ground state
ini adalah masalah besar karena semakin lambat kita harus membiarkan sesuatu berevolusi semakin banyak waktu yang kita miliki untuk error
terjadi, counter adiabatic driving yang sering disingkat CD bertujuan untuk memerangi ini dengan
menambahkan suku-suku yang melawan eksitasi yang tidak diinginkan ini, ide utamanya adalah untuk mempercepat seluruh eksperimen dan
mengurangi kedalaman Quantum circuit dengan menekan eksitasi yang bisa mengarah pada transisi
spurious, sekarang mari kita bahas apa itu bias field, algoritma iteratif lainnya seperti VQE mengambil parameter klasik ke dalam
state-state tersebut dan menggunakan classical optimizer untuk mencari ruang parameter berdimensi banyak untuk menemukan set
yang menghasilkan nilai ekspektasi minimum untuk hamiltonian yang tetap, dalam kasus ini mereka malah memvariasikan hamiltonian setiap
WEBVTT
kali bergerak secara adiabatik dari kasus yang diketahui ke kasus yang diminati tapi karena tidak ada parameter klasik yang
dimasukkan dan tidak ada fungsi gelombang variasional bagaimana kamu memperbarui state kamu dari satu pasasi ke hamiltonian ke berikutnya? well
mereka menambahkan bias field ke hamiltonian, state energi terendah dari operasi sebelumnya, mereka menambahkan suku dalam
hamiltonian untuk memberi bias state demi itu, jadi mengapa eksperimen ini
menarik? well pertama-tama ini adalah pendekatan baru yang bisa diterapkan secara lebih umum ke masalah optimasi lainnya
tapi dalam kasus ini mereka menerapkannya ke masalah Ising spin glass, seperti yang kita bahas sebelumnya banyak masalah optimasi
kombinatorial bisa dirumuskan ulang sebagai menyelesaikan state energi rendah dari hamiltonians Ising, model
Ising adalah serangkaian spin mikroskopik yang didistribusikan pada sebuah array, model ini bisa digunakan untuk mendeskripsikan spin glass di mana
magnetisasinya tidak teratur, pada dasarnya momen-momen magnetik kecil tersebut berorientasi secara acak dalam array dan
mengapa kita pikir ini akan berhasil? well kita sudah cukup membahas bagaimana kita memerangi dua masalah umum yang ditemukan dalam
algoritma variasional ketika kita membahas definisi-definisi dari paper tapi untuk merangkum, algoritma yang mereka
usulkan mempercepat evolusi untuk mengurangi kedalaman circuit sekaligus menekan transisi non-adiabatik
selain itu tidak bergantung pada rutinitas classical optimization apa pun yang bisa menjadi masalah yang mengarah ke Barren
plateaus dan terjebak di minima lokal, terakhir para penulis juga memastikan untuk menyelaraskan interaksi dalam masalah
hamiltonian dengan konektivitas hardware di QPU nyata yang selalu sangat penting, terakhir bagaimana ini berhasil? jadi
seperti yang aku katakan tidak ada classical optimizer yang digunakan di sini seperti yang sering ada dalam algoritma Quantum iteratif
sebagai gantinya dengan memasukkan solusi dari setiap iterasi ke dalam input untuk yang berikutnya, bias field digitized
quantum optimization algorithm secara bertahap menyempurnakan ground state sehingga semakin mendekati
state terevoluasi akhir dan dikombinasikan dengan protokol counter adiabatic kita bisa melakukan ini bahkan dengan Quantum circuit
berkedalaman pendek yang seharusnya berjalan lancar di hardware yang noisy, jadi ketika eksperimen dilakukan para penulis memilih untuk menjalankan
algoritma pada komputer kuantum IBM 127 qubit Brisbane, di sini penulisnya menunjukkan
energetisasi dari algoritma optimasi untuk instance spin glass yang dihasilkan secara acak dengan nearest neighbor
lebih dari 100 qubit, mereka membandingkan hasil simulasi ideal dari DCQ dan BF DCQ
serta hasil eksperimental dan mereka juga menunjukkan hasil dari classical solver yang disebut GUROBI sebagai referensi, sekarang
hanya dengan 10 iterasi BF DCQ memberikan peningkatan drastis dibandingkan dengan
DCQ meskipun hasil eksperimental sedikit berbeda dari hasil ideal karena noise, performanya masih
lebih baik dari DCQ ideal, ini menunjukkan bahwa masih ada banyak kemajuan luar biasa yang sedang dibuat terkait
dengan optimasi Quantum dan hasil yang baik sedang dilaporkan pada lebih dari 100 qubit untuk pertama kalinya
yang terakhir tapi tidak kalah pentingnya adalah paper yang sangat menarik mengeksplorasi prediksi struktur mRNA dari teman-teman kita di
Moderna Pharmaceuticals dan ini disebut mRNA secondary structure prediction using utility scale quantum
computers, untuk memulai kalau kamu seperti aku yang belum mengambil kursus biologi dalam beberapa tahun kamu bisa menyegarkan diri tentang apa
itu mRNA, messenger RNA adalah jenis RNA yang terlibat dalam sintesis protein,
pada dasarnya membaca instruksi yang diberikan oleh DNA, struktur sekunder mRNA kurang lebih adalah bagaimana rantai tersebut dilipat dan
masalah prediksi struktur sekunder RNA adalah masalah menemukan lipatan paling stabil dari urutan
basa nukleotida yang membentuk DNA dan RNA yaitu C G U dan A, gambar ini menunjukkan beberapa struktur lipatan umum yang ditemukan dalam mRNA, setiap warna yang disorot di sini menunjukkan
struktur sekunder yang berbeda tapi karakteristik tepat untuk apa yang membuat salah satu struktur ini lebih menguntungkan dari
yang lain tidak dipahami dengan baik, yang bisa kita lakukan hanyalah mencari tahu yang mana yang memiliki energi bebas terendah dibandingkan dengan
state yang tidak terlipat dan di situlah komputer kuantum berperan, jadi mengapa struktur sekunder mRNA
itu penting? well prediksi yang akurat dari mereka sebenarnya sangat penting tidak hanya untuk memahami DNA dan gen kita tapi juga
untuk merancang terapeutik berbasis RNA seperti vaksin covid-19, ada alasan untuk percaya bahwa pendekatan dalam
paper ini akan berhasil karena ini sudah lama dikenal sebagai masalah optimasi yang tangguh untuk
komputer klasik karena banyaknya kemungkinan konfigurasi dan untuk beberapa konfigurasi sebenarnya diketahui menjadi
masalah NP complete, namun pada komputer kuantum kita bisa merumuskan prediksi struktur sekunder sebagai masalah
optimasi biner yang kita tahu cara menanganinya, selain itu sudah ada bukti dalam literatur
tentang prediksi RNA yang akurat pada perangkat Quantum skala kecil dan simulator Quantum, jadi pertanyaan yang jelas adalah
apakah ini akan berhasil pada hardware yang lebih besar? eksperimen dilakukan dengan menggunakan sesuatu yang disebut conditional value
at risk variational quantum eigensolver yang merupakan modifikasi dari algoritma VQE tradisional dan
diharapkan mencapai konvergensi yang lebih baik, plot ini menunjukkan distribusi probabilitas pengukuran
dari sampel bit string dengan energi yang sesuai untuk instance
42 nukleotida 80 qubit, di sini bit string melambangkan pasangan dari
nukleotida, ini mengilustrasikan bahwa bit string berenergi terendah memiliki nilai energi minus 140 yang sesuai dengan
bit string berenergi terendah yang ditemukan oleh classical solver komparatif, jadi itu bagus dan ini adalah struktur terlipat optimal dari rantai
nukleotida tersebut berdasarkan bit string berenergi terendah yang ditemukan oleh hardware
dan dengan itu kita telah mencapai kesimpulan dari episode ini, sekarang tujuan aku di sini bukan untuk membanjiri kamu dengan
detail dari paper penelitian yang berbeda, seperti yang aku katakan aku hanya ingin memberi kamu semua konteks yang cukup untuk memahami seperti apa
pekerjaan mutakhir di bidang ini saat ini, harapannya adalah ini akan menggerakkan beberapa roda
dalam kepala semua orang dan bahwa dengan melihat bagaimana orang lain mendekati masalah kamu akan bisa membuat koneksi dan memiliki
kepercayaan diri untuk mencoba eksperimen Quantum baru yang mungkin belum pernah kamu coba sebelumnya dan hey mungkin beberapa dari itu tidak
berhasil dan tidak apa-apa, itulah mengapa ini adalah penelitian, ke depan ingat bahwa jenis masalah yang
kita minati bisa dikelompokkan baik berdasarkan metodologi atau subjek dan kita telah memaparkan yang kita yakini menjadi
WEBVTT
yang paling menjanjikan dalam jangka pendek, ingat Quantum Computing tidak bagus untuk segalanya dan sebenarnya ini hanya
bukti betapa bagusnya kita dalam komputasi klasik, hanya karena kamu pikir kamu bisa menerapkan Quantum Computing
pada suatu masalah bukan berarti akan menghasilkan hasil yang menarik, sayangnya kamu harus mempertimbangkan scaling, kedalaman circuit
adalah pedang bermata dua, kita perlu itu cukup besar untuk melakukan pekerjaan menarik yang tidak bisa
dilakukan komputer klasik tapi saat ini karena noise hardware kita tidak bisa mendorongnya ke ukuran yang sangat besar karena fidelity akan
berkurang, ini semua tentang menemukan sweet spot itu dan mengetahui bahwa itu adalah target yang bergerak, jadi luangkan waktu
antara sekarang dan episode berikutnya untuk benar-benar memikirkan beberapa masalah yang kamu temui dan bagaimana kamu mungkin ingin mendekatinya dengan apa yang telah kita
pelajari sampai titik ini, jadilah kreatif dan jangan batasi dirimu dan kalau kamu punya ide bahkan kalau kamu pikir itu sedikit
gila kasih tahu aku di kolom komentar di bawah, terima kasih sudah menonton dan sampai jumpa lain waktu